Ron, Jesse, I'm renaming this
competition papa don't take no
mess because it's just the
patriarchs of the families
going at it in our final round
of this competition where
we're sending you back to
your home forges to recreate
this iconic weapon
from history, the Inigo
Montoya-inspired rapier.
You know the guy.
You killed my father.
Prepare to forge, all right.
Good luck bladesmiths.
We'll see you in four days.
RON: I am almost
positive that they're
going to do some kind of a flex
test, so I'm choosing ADCR-V2.
That should help with that.
The hilt is one of the
more complex pieces here.
I'm actually going to use
some really old wrought iron.
One of the really nice
things about wrought iron
is that it's beautiful.
My plan is to [inaudible]
so you can see
the lines around this thing.
I'm working on my normalization.
This is make or break.
If it works well, I'm all set.
I grab hold of it with another
pair of tongs and go for it.
I am very pleased right now to
have, at the end of day one,
a quenched blade
ready for temper.
So far I'm on track.
JESSE: After coming
out of the temper,
I noticed that there was just a
slight little yaw in the edge.
[inaudible] take all of
that out and grind it today.
Next, I'm going to
move on to the hilt.
I'm planning on
forging all the parts
for the hilt out of
an old wagon wheel
that my grandfather used to own.
So I'm flipping it over, and
I ended up getting a crack.
Got a small crack that's
developed in the piece
that I was forging
for my pommel.
I'm going to try to see if I
can get that crack out of it.
Luckily took one more
good, hot welded heat,
and we're good to go.
I feel better today
than I did on day one.
End of day two, I'm ready
to go put my feet up.
RON: Well, my goal
is to actually
get done with the blade today.
It leaves me two days to work
on all of the embellishments.
I may get into doing some
of the hilt work today.
I want to see how it
goes with the grinding.
If I over grind, I could
completely destroy the blade.
There's a reason that it
took Inigo Montoya's father
a year to make this sword.
There are so many
pieces to this.
But for Jessica, I'm going to
get this done in four days.
JESSE: I got a little bit
behind where I would like to be.
I'm going to try to
make up a little time.
I'm going to go ahead and
forge out my knuckle-bow,
and hopefully by lunchtime when
you start fabricating the hilt.
This hilt's been
pretty demanding.
There's about six
different pieces here.
We spent a lot of time trying
to make sure everything
was dialed in.
End of day three, my hilt all
came together pretty nicely.
Just pulled it out of the etch.
Everything looks good.
Tomorrow will just
be fit and finish.
RON: Last day, I have to
get done, well, everything.
Now I can focus on getting
that really complex
handle and hilt all together.
I'm forging out these
bigger rings that
are on the side of the hand.
That's eventually
going to become
this really complex basket.
Not perfect, but for
day four, I'll take it.
Regardless of the
outcome on this thing,
I've had a blast making this.
Win, lose, or draw, it's
just been so much fun.
Good job.
Thank you.
All right, bladesmiths,
my name is Douglas Marcaida.
I will kill the dummies.
They are prepared to die.
To find out what kind of lethal
damage your weapons will do,
I will take your
rapiers and deliver
some thrusts and slashes
on this ballistics dummy.
Ron, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Absolutely.
Let's do it.
[music playing]
All right, Ron, let's
talk about your rapier here.
It is a little bit
on the heavier side,
but it's wieldable.
And with a nice swish of
a slash, it cuts deeply.
Overall, sir, your
rapier, it will kill.
Good job.
Thank you
All right, Jesse,
it's your turn.
You ready, sir?
Yes, sir.
Let's do this.
JESSE: I'm extremely nervous.
I immediately start
questioning my heat treat.
And, you know, just a million
things go through your head.
[music playing]
All right, Jesse, let's
talk about your blade here.
It's about the same weight.
The thrusts penetrate
all the way.
And slash, well, deep cuts.
Overall, sir, your
blade will kill.
Thank you, sir.
It's what I came to hear.
All right, gentlemen, it's
time for the strength test.
And yes, I am going to
torture your blades.
Ron, you're up first.
All right.
If you haven't guessed
already, it's a flex test.
RON: I'm feeling a little
nervous coming into this test.
If I left any uneven
spots, that could impact
the flexibility of that blade.
Good job, man.
Good job.
OK, Ron, that's a brutal
test, and you did really well.
If you look at
your blade, there's
the slightest of bend in one
direction, barely noticeable.
The dimensions of the
guard are spot on,
and it's definitely
a strong blade.
Nicely done.
Thank you very much.
Jesse, you ready for this?
About as nervous
as a long-tailed
cat in a room full of
rocking chairs, but go ahead.
[laughs]
First things, Jesse, the
guard's at the proper scale.
Really nicely done.
The issue is you've
picked a bit of a bend.
Still a completely
functional, usable blade.
Well done.
Thank you.
Bladesmiths, this
is the sharpness test.
This is all about how
sharp your blade is
and what it does to this dummy.
Ron, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Yes, sir.
DOUG: Let's do this.
[music playing]
All right, Ron, let's
talk about your edge here.
This cut through the clothing
and right into the foam.
And, of course, when
thrusting, it goes deep.
Overall, sir, it will cut.
Thank you.
All right, Jesse,
it's your turn, sir.
You ready?
- Yes, sir.
DOUG: Let's do this.
[music playing]
All right, Jesse,
I can still see
the little bend it
took at the tip,
but the edges are razor sharp.
On the thrust, it goes deep.
It will cut.
Thank you, sir.
Ron, Jesse, you
guys have turned
in some really quality blades.
This is a difficult
decision for us to make,
and our "Forged in
Fire" champion is Ron.
Congratulations.
You are the new "Forged
in Fire" champion.
Jesse, please
surrender your blade.
JESSE: Not being
the "Forged in Fire"
champion is kind of not
what I was looking for,
but I lost to a
heck of a competitor
and a heck of a blade.
- Well done.
Thank you.
I'm very proud of the
blade I turned in,
but if I made this
blade again, I
would have took a little
more time on my heat treat,
made sure I had it perfect.
Being able to start this journey
with my son was pretty awesome.
And I may not be the
"Forged in Fire" champion,
but I think I represented
my family well.
Ron, congratulations.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion.
You've led your family
to this position,
and you'll be taking
home a check for $10,000.
Good job, brother.
RON: From beginning to end, this
has been a great experience.
So the Hardman house is
getting a "Forged in Fire"
championship.